back to CBS this morning from Washington
I'm Anthony Mason with tonita copal and
Michelle Miller Gayle King is off we
still do not have a full picture of the
corona virus outbreak in the u.s. in
part because of a major shortage in
testing supplies Trump administration
officials have promised millions of
tests but we spoken to doctors and
potential patients who say they're not
getting them Joseph Lanza tried to get
tested in hard-hit New Rochelle north of
New York City
they pretty much asked me when I was
feeling which was scratchy throat
headache achy bones a little bit of
fever but since I didn't have a hundred
and two fever they they didn't want to
give me the the virus test and I think
they're short of the virus tests I'm not
as concerned about myself it's it's the
damage that my having the virus can do
to the people around me dr. Jon LaPook
joins us from New York to help explain
why this has been such a problem as this
crisis unfolds good morning dr. LaPook
good morning morning Michelle we just
heard from dr. Fauci in our last
half-hour that he's optimistic that
we're going to get more tests out there
to more people but the question is
everyone wants to get tested now if they
have a sore throat if they have a slight
fever where do they go and what should
they do well with it
yeah they don't what what people don't
want you to do is to just go into a
doctor's office or go into a hospital
emergency room unannounced right because
you don't want to be infecting other
people if you do happen to have kovin 19
so we're talking about triaging people
from a distance and that means being in
your apartment or in your home and
calling your doctor if you or a
clinician if you don't have one there
are hotlines so New York State
Department of Health for example has one
that you check with your Department of
Health or call the hospital and then
they'll triage you they'll figure out
what you should do from a distance if
they do decide you need testing they can
give you instructions so people are
waiting for you and it's safe everybody
has protective gear when you do come in
how quickly the FDA John we talked about
this early in the broadcast just issued
an emergency authorization for a test
that can give
results in about three and a half hours
how important is it to get tests that we
can get results faster yeah Anthony
that's huge right because right now
there's such a bottleneck what's
happening in the trenches and I've
spoken to so many doctors is first of
all think about it normally you go into
doctor's office you have a sore throat
you want to get a strep test they can do
it no problem they test it right there
here you need special protective gear so
a lot of offices aren't even set up for
that then if they've got to send it to
another lab that lab may or may not be
set up to quickly process it so they may
not have the technicians to do the tests
and then after that you know it's very
it's it's complicated it's not simple to
do you have to extract the RNA the
genetic material and you have to do
special stuff with special machines and
then it may take a long time to get the
results it could be a day I'm hearing a
day or two sometimes to get the results
so it's a big deal if you could do it
rapidly it would be even a bigger deal
if you could do it in your own home
I hear the Gates Foundation and others
are actually working on something like
that wouldn't that be great doctor maybe
the phrase of the day if not the week
has been flattening the curve people are
hearing it can you say what it is and
how all these cancellations may help
flatten that curve right alright people
feel out of control right now right what
can you do and is it really worthwhile
to do all of this social distancing and
hand-washing and all that stuff and the
answer is yes I'm going to use a
chalkboard right in front of me right
normally right now without any measures
the epidemic might go up and go down
that peak number of people who have the
cases can overload the system that's
what people are worried about there may
not be enough doctors the doctors may
get sick other clinicians health
professionals may get sick you may not
have enough ventilators other medical
equipment it's a stress on the system if
you can do all of these measures and
flatten out that curve so instead of a
peak up and down it's sort of slowly
going out it's still going up and the
epidemic may actually last longer but
it's not putting such a stress on the
system at that moment so that would be a
very big deal does it work
yes it works we saw in China the number
of cases come down new cases in South
Korea where they did aggressive testing
that it was so clever right they had
drive in people were safely able to be
tested in their cars and we're seeing
their cases go down and in the 1918 flu
epidemic in the pandemic we saw that
social distancing worked and so as as
scary as some of these cancellations can
be as
nerving as they are